61 jours après, 61 c'est ce qu'il a rencontré.
Il avait perdu ses clefs, Ses parents l'ont oublié.
Donc un jour après les cours, Il est entré dans une maison.
Il a remarqué sur le seuil, Ce numéro trompe-l’œil.
Quel diable l'a pris De ne jamais se présenter.
Elle l'a laissé entrer, Il est resté ébahi.
61 avait tout de 60, Plus un chouilla. (Rires)
Des yeux plus jolis, Un sourire communicatif.
Cool comme lui, Le même brut de décoffrage.
Comme chez lui, Tout est empilé dans le chaos,
Comme lui, peu chaut sa mère Si des amis y passent la nuit.
Elle et lui, pareils. Déjà, il l'aimait.
Il croit qu'elle aussi peut l'aimer, sachant qu'il est comme elle.
Cette fois, c'est la bonne. Cette fille l'a ensorcelé.
Alors il a pris son courage à deux mains, Lui a demandé sa main.
« Je suis 61 », a-t-elle dit. « Je suis 59 », a-t-il souri.
C'était super aujourd'hui.
Demain, si tu veux, Chez moi, ce sera mieux.
Elle a dit : « ça roule ».
Elle adorait parler A quelqu'un d'aussi décalé.
Elle accepta ce premier rendez-vous officieux
Finalement, il était prêt Une minute trop tôt.
Ça n'a pas d'incidence, Elle avait une minute de retard.
Dès cet instant, Leur bavardage fut incessant.
Tous deux adorent « X Factor », Tous deux ont deux facteurs.
Peu importe d'ailleurs. Leur singularité les rend meilleurs.
Au bout de la nuit, ils le savaient L'un pour l'autre, ils étaient faits
Un jour, elle parlait de 60, Délaissée et affectée.
Chez 59, elle remarqua, Son regard évasif.
Il rougit et lui dit Son amour furtif.
« La meilleure chose jamais arrivée Parce qu'elle nous a réunis. »
61 était futée, sans penchant pour la jalousie.
Les yeux dans les yeux, Avec douceur, elle lui a dit :
« Tu es 59. Moi, je suis 61. Ensemble, le double de 60. »
(Rires)
59 en a le regard brouillé.
Heureux d'avoir trouvé Cette fille unique.
Il lui parla du sens D'être premiers.
Son cœur ne peut se diviser Qu'avec celui d'une seule.
C'est à elle seule, Qu'il veut donner son cœur.
Elle avoua ses sentiments pareils. Les films ont à moitié raison.
Parlant d'amours fictifs, Des échantillons.
Du vrai amour, Ils en sont l'exemple premier.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
C'était mon tout premier poème.
Je l'ai écrit pour une soirée poésie sur le thème des nombres premiers. (Rires)
En fait, une compétition de poésie sur le thème des nombres premiers.
Ce qui a fait de moi un poète lauréat sur le thème des nombres premiers.
J'aime raccourcir ce titre en premier ministre. (Rires)
C'est ainsi que j'ai découvert la poésie slam.
Pour ceux et celles qui ne savent pas ce que c'est,
la poésie slam est née en Amérique il y a 30 ans,
une astuce pour attirer les gens dans des soirées de poésie,
en ajoutant le mot à la mode « slam ».
(Rires)
Chaque participant a trois minutes.
L'audience, très aléatoire, note un score sur un panneau,
qui, additionné les uns aux autres, donne un score final.
Le résultat c'est qu'il n'y a plus de barrière entre le poète et le public.
Ça entraîne une sorte de lien avec son public.
Et ça signifie aussi qu'on peut gagner.
Quand on gagne une poésie slam, on devient un champion du slam.
On peut prétendre être un battant.
Mais si on perd, on peut relativiser et dire :
« La poésie est un art subjectif. Ce n'est pas quantifiable. »
(Rires)
J'ai adoré ça. Je m'y suis engagé.
Et je suis devenu le champion du slam en Angleterre.
On m'a invité à Paris, à la Coupe du Monde de Poésie.
C'était incroyable.
Des gens de partout dans le monde, parlant dans leur langue natale
sont jugés par 5 Français.
(Rires)
Je ne sais pas pourquoi, mais j'ai gagné. C'était super !
Depuis, je voyage dans le monde.
Ça signifie aussi que mon prochain poème
est techniquement le meilleur du monde.
(Rires)
Bon...
(Applaudissements)
C'est ce qu'ont dit 5 Français.
Voici « Des personnes en papier »
J'aime les personnes.
J'aimerais avoir des personnes en papier.
Des personnes en papier pourpre. Des personnes pop-up en papier pourpre.
Des personnes pop-up propres en papier pourpre.
Comment porter des personnes pop-up en papier pourpre ?
Je t'entends pleurer. En fait...
Probablement, je porterais des personnes pop-up propres en papier pourpre
avec un trombone pour des personnes pop-up propres en papier pourpre.
Je pré-préparerais des adhésifs appropriés comme alternative
un paquet moqueur de patafix, au cas où le papier patine.
Je pourrais bâtir une métropole pop-up.
Mais je ne veux pas m'engager dans la politique des personnes en papier.
Des politiciens en papier, aux politiques aussi minces qu'un papier.
Des promesses non-respectées, sans regret approprié.
Il y aurait un petit moi en papier, et un petit toi en papier.
On regarderait TV papier. Papier pas pier-re
(Rires)
Des rappeurs de papier pompeux y rapperaient sur leur paquet en papier.
Des rames de personnes en papier seraient à l'arrêt sur la A4
(Rires) Format.
Il y aurait la Princesse Kate en papier, Mais nous ne regardons que Pippa en papier
Nous vivrions tous dans la crainte De Jack le Déchiqueteur.
Parce que la propagande de papier Propage les préjudices des personnes,
Les papiers impriment des photos De terroristes photogéniques.
Un petit moi de papier, Un petit toi de papier.
Dans une population pop-up, les problèmes des personnes se propagent aussi.
Il y aurait un pompeux parlement en papier Qui resterait toujours débranché,
Ignorant les protestations des personnes Sur les coupes du papier,
Les protestations pacifiques de papier, Seraient réduites en morceaux
Par les canons à confettis De la police préventive.
Argent en papier et cupidité Pourtant persisteraient.
Les banquiers grippe-sou en papier Qui empochent plus que nécessaire
Achèteraient du pot-pourri Pour persiller leur propriété de papier.
D'autres vivant dans l'indigence, N'auraient pas de reconnaissance.
Une propre économie pauvre Où tant sont proprement pauvres
Où leurs besoins sont ignorés L'argent va dans les guerres.
Des armées d'origami Déplient des plans d'avions en papier
Nous restons menottés Dans nos chaînes de papier
Le plus grand déshonneur Tout semble toujours pareil
Change juste la personne chargée De dire qui porte la responsabilité
Ils donnent des noms Oubliant que ce sont les noms de personnes
Après tout, On en revient aux personnes.
J'aime les personnes.
Même quand la situation est grave,
Ce sont uniquement les personnes qui peuvent nous inspirer,
et sur papier, Impossible de voir comment opérer
Dans le fond de la boîte de Pandore, Il y a l'espoir,
J'ai toujours espoir Dans l'humanité des personnes.
Des personnes comme mes grands-parents
Qui chaque jour depuis ma naissance,
Tous les matins, prennent le temps De prier pour moi.
7892 jours d'affilée Quelqu'un s'assure que je vais bien.
C'est inouï.
Des personnes comme ma tante, Qui passe du temps avec des prisonniers.
Des personnes capables De pardon sincère.
Des personnes comme les Palestiniens persécutés.
Des personnes qui se démènent Pour rendre notre vie meilleure
Sans rien espérer en retour. Les personnes ont le potentiel d'être exceptionnelles.
Peu importe si les personnes au pouvoir Prétendent être des victimes.
Ne succombons pas au système.
Une population de papier est pareille.
Il y a un petit moi de papier Et un petit toi de papier.
Dans une population pop-up, les problèmes des personnes se propagent.
Même si le monde implose, Nous survivrons.
Parce que nous sommes Des personnes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup. J'ai juste le temps pour un autre.
Pour moi, la poésie est la forme ultime des idées sans frontières.
A mes débuts,
ceux qui m'ont inspiré avaient des histoires exceptionnelles.
Je pensais, du haut de mes 18 ans, sans soucis, que j'étais trop normal.
Mais je pouvais créer ces mondes dans lesquels je parle de mes expériences,
de mes rêves, de mes convictions.
C'est fabuleux d'être ici devant vous.
Merci d'être là. Si vous n'étiez pas là
Aujourd'hui ressemblerait à hier, pendant le test de son.
(Rires)
C'est plus sympa aujourd'hui.
Ce dernier poème s'appelle « Le gosse du Soleil ».
Merci de m'écouter.
Le vieux soleil était fier de son fils rayon,
Ses journées, ensoleillées Par l'éclat de son petit garçon
Pas pour ses accomplissements, Ni pour les problèmes résolus.
Parce qu'en dépit de ses dispositions Son caractère restait illuminé.
Ça n'a pas toujours été ainsi.
Par moments, il a essayé De cacher sa luminosité
Toute étoile, voyez, Endure épreuves et adversité.
Seule une lumière plus brillante Les inspire dans l'obscurité.
Quand il est né dans une nébuleuse,
Tous savaient qu'il ne serait jamais Considéré comme ordinaire
Il avait déjà cet air de dire « les doigts de Midas ont tort »
Mais tout qui s'en approche Semble briller de mille feux
Ce soleil était adoré Par certains plus que d'autres
Il en est ainsi de Joseph, De son manteau multicolore, de ses frères
Sortir du lot A des avantages et des inconvénients
La jalousie a fait des ennemis De ceux qu'il éclipse,
Comme les « gens de l'ombre ».
Ces gens n'aimaient pas Le Gosse du Soleil
Parce qu'il éclairait les ténèbres Créées par les gens de l'ombre.
En brillant, il mettait au jour les cachettes des gens de l'ombre.
Alors ils ont voulu s'en débarrasser.
Ils se sont moqué de ses taches,
Tirant sur ses rêves depuis le ciel Des mots sortis d'un fusil
Destinés à lui rappeler Qu'il n'est pas très cool
Qu'à l'école, il n'est pas ami avec les enfants populaires.
Ils prétendent qu'il est dans la lune Qu'ils vont le ramener sur terre
Qu'il vient de rien Que c'est ce qu'il vaut
Qu'il n'ira jamais à l'université
Les seuls titres dont il peut se targuer Sont les brûlures au premier degré
De ceux qui s'approchent trop. Ils lui dirent qu'il était trop brillant
Voilà pourquoi personne Ne le regarde jamais dans les yeux
Son jugement s'est obscurci Le ciel aussi
De larmes évaporées Quand le soleil s'est mis à pleurer.
Parce que le Gosse du Soleil était ardent Béni d'une personnalité chaleureuse
Dans son for, il brûle ardemment
Blessé par les mots et les malédictions Des gens de l'ombre
Qui ont creusé dans son âme Des cavités
Quand son cœur s'est solidifié Son éclat a faibli
A chaque insulte Ses flammes s'éteignent.
Il espérait qu'ils l'aimeraient Si sa lumière restait sombre
Préoccupés de lancer des flèches Sans bien viser
Il ne comprend pas bien Leurs propos
Alors il a laissé leurs mots Eclipser sa lumière
Et est tombé dans l'Etat de l'Etoile Solitaire, comme le Texas,
Comme si on lui avait écrasé Le plexus solaire
C'est alors qu'est arrivée Ptite Dame Rayon de Soleil
Chantant son chant favori sur combien nous sommes forts
Pas besoin d'avoir tort pour être accepté Etre sincère avec soi-même suffit
Parce que dans notre âme Nous sommes tous des étoiles
Ptite Dame Rayon de Soleil Etait chaude
Le genre de fille Quand tu la mates,
T'en oublies la date
Mais lui, il ne l'oublia point
La minute où il l'a vue Son image a brûlé sa rétine
Venue d'un autre monde, Elle l'a accepté
Quelque chose chez elle fait qu'il sait Chaque fois qu'elle s'assied à côté
Rien n'est aussi sombre qu'il n'y paraît Et se remet à rêver.
Plus d'ombres à l'horizon Quand elle est là, il brille
Ses yeux s'illuminent D'une ardeur qu'on ne peut simuler
Son sourire efface Les blessures des mots de haine
Ils se sont surnommés « Etoile Cool » et « Soleil Fun »
Graduellement, se sont effacés Les ombrages
Elle était une parmi un quadrillion Et elle était brillante
Elle pouvait rendre vermillon Le plus froid des reptiles
Adorée par des millions Du Chili au Brésil,
Elle a appris au Gosse du Soleil Le sens de la résistance.
Elle a dit : « Toute l'obscurité du monde
Ne peut éteindre la lumière D'une seule chandelle
Alors, comment peuvent-ils contrôler ta lumière ?
Seul toi peut choisir de l'obscurcir, Le ciel est ta limite
Rabats le caquet aux critiques et brille. »
Si les yeux sont les fenêtres de l'âme Alors, elle a ouvert les rideaux
Et laissé passer les rayons de soleil A travers la douleur.
Dans un univers d'adversité Ces deux étoiles sont ensemble
Les jours deviennent nuits, Mais les souvenirs sont immortels
Quoi qu'en dise Monsieur Météo, Tout s'arrangera
Car derrière les nuages Le gosse peut toujours briller.
Le gosse du soleil était brillant, Avec une personnalité chaleureuse,
Brûlant d'un feu intérieur
Nourri des feux inspirés des galaxies
Par la fille qui lui a montré Comment croire en lui.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)